i was really surprised to read something
about you
when you were a young man
and you were looking to get in the nba
and then you get in the nba
you would spend hours on end watching
videotapes of your opponents
and you would study where the ball would
fall after they shot
so that you could rebound how many hours
a day would you spend watching videotape
it depends on i started that when i was
in san antonio and when i left detroit
a lot of people want to see me fail so
the the truth be told you were pretty
serious about basketball the fact that
you'd stud
you'd say to them look we're playing the
knicks tonight here's what i want
give me a video tape of the last couple
of games i'm gonna sit and watch it and
then what would you do
the ball you would see the ball come off
the rim the way a guy would shoot i was
just i would just
just watch um especially my teammates
i'll watch what uh uh the angles of the
floor where they go
and position themselves to shoot the
ball right and i'll just sit there and
watch it
just watch the path of the ball go to
the rim and most of the time you can see
him it's going to be short it's going to
be
long it's going to go straight up or
come out to the side right and stuff
like that i just go
go to the videotape and watch the
opponents and i said wow you know
so could you get to the point where when
you were going to play a specific team
and you were going to be
watching some players shoot the ball you
could tell 99 of the time where the ball
would land
absolutely pretty much you know like i
guess i'm on the biggest guy i was like
like 200 pounds right six foot seven
whatever and mostly i was like
six foot six 250 260 pounds right a lot
more stronger but i was just more
more focused and uh i just wanted to uh
prove to people hey i always deserve to
be there why do you think you have the
reputation then for not working hard
because you i mean this is a guy with
tremendous focus this is a guy who's
saying i'm going to study these goddamn
tapes so i can figure out the trajectory
of this ball and the rebound
well you know what how a lot a lot of
guys a lot of people
in the world really looked at me like uh
dennis uh since i was in chicago
right and i was doing so many things on
and off the court and they said wow he's
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] he i mean he
just don't give a damn i said wait a
minute
i don't give a damn i got two
championship rings i'm reaping the ball
like crazy i'm in chicago i got three
more championship rings i was always
there every day
no one basically complained about the
instrument so i'm a [ __ ]
but you were really shocked that they're
inducting you they're retiring your
number
you you were moved to tears that they
were retiring your number
and that you are going to be in the
basketball hall of fame
right you you were moved to tears well
i'll just move because the fact that
it wasn't that i was just i was
emotionally
shocked or emotionally like just
distraught because i was that my
number's gonna retire it was just a fact
i couldn't believe they was doing it and
because you know i was i wasn't there
significantly but i was just a piece of
the team but i said you know
i shouldn't be you guys shouldn't be
doing this for me because i i don't
deserve this
i'm going to play the clip now of you
finding out the news here you always you
always
here it is it's an emotional dennis
rodman and i and i'm moved by this
yes i am it's surprising to me because i
i just feel like that you know
a lot of uh
i i just feel like i didn't do too i
deserved to have my number retired
because i didn't do
as much as i should here you say i
didn't deserve to have my number retired
because i didn't do as much as i should
have
yeah do you really believe that i
believe that you could have worked
harder in the nba
no i wasn't working harder i think i
should have been a lot longer than i was
i mean i think my my whole time there
i think probably four years was very
significant
for that organization that's the reason
i was saying that because it could have
been at least 10 11 12 years but
it didn't work out that way and i said
you know for my number to get retired i
kept trying to go back and forth
why are these guys doing this to me
because i was only here for six years
and um chuck daley bless his soul he
died a couple years ago and uh that
would really
got me a really emotional because i
actually had a shirt with bill davidson
and chuck daley with their faces on i
showed the whole crowd
because they should be here with this
and it wasn't here so i just put their
face on t-shirt they're showing you all
this love i think it really rocked you
it was just funny danny plush when i
went back there i haven't been back
there so long
and i saw so many people that that
really really actually cared about
dennis rodman that i was with all the
damn time
and so many people on the pistons you
know and those guys really uh
really are really excited some love but
i just couldn't believe it that you see
joe dumas you see isaac thomas you see
rick rahorn you see john sally you see
vinny johnson
right and you see all the other guys
that was on the team uh
it's just it's like that you're looking
for the rapture it's only nine players
up there
right and john sally said wow why don't
you get your name retired i haven't got
my number retired i said well you went
with the [ __ ]